Mình chỉ lưng thực thế giới về K&P, ngày mềm bệnh thống vào kệng báo,
xung đồ liên quan tự ưa ra nếu kéo dài đến thằng sau có thể lời thêm khoảng 4,5 trộng rồi vào tình chạm bỏ cấp tính,
nâng tổng sống người kêu lưng thực quan cầu vượt mất kỳ lúc két này là bà trọng mời chiến chiều.
Theo VEKP, các khu tấn công của Mỹ và Iceran đã làm giảm đoạn góc tuyên vất chuyển biển chợi nhìn đau,
đặc biệt là ở bên hoặc mốt.
Đừng thời đầy giá thức phẩm năng lượng và chi phí vận tải tăng mạnh.
Chỉ phí vận chuyển lưng thực tự góc của ra và các cộng lộng thiêu đổi của VEKP đã tăng khoảng 14,5 trộng bị tuyên
hằng 2,5 thái đổi lúc trình trong khi mọi người tài trộng của tế, thì ngày gặng tuyệt.
Trong một dịch biến linh quan, cùng ngày văn phòng nhìn quên linh được quốc của bây tỏ lòng ngại
các cuộc không việc WISRAN nhằm bao lúc đổi hiệu bói lạng đã li bằng,
đã chúng mục tiêu vào khu dân cờ, công đồng đăng sơ tán và các cơ sở hi tế,
hãy động này có thể vi phạm lần đến đau của tế.
Giờ chức li bằng cho biết các độ không kích WISRAN đã kiến tính nhất tám trăm tảm mấy sống với tế mạng
và hương một chiều người phải dồi bỏ nhạc gờ.
Và tinh trạng người dân phải dây dờ của tức tục ra tăng nghen trống,
lươi phố kêu gó các bên kiếm trế, bảo vệ dân thường và nằm bảo hòa độ vệ trợ không bị dán đoạn,
trong buổi cạnh xuống lột tại chúng lông đăng lâu thang.